- English is the most widely
spoken language on the planet.
Research estimates that there are upwards
of 1.5 billion English speakers worldwide.
That's billion with a B,
more than 18% of the
entire global population.
But how did English become the
most widely spoken language
in the world,
and why are there so many
different kinds of Englishes?
Well, the first kind
of answers the second.
There are so many
different world Englishes
because there are just
so many English speakers,
with diverse cultural
and societal influences
impacting their language use.
I'm speaking American English
because I was born, raised.
and educated in the United States,
but there are over 160 different
Englishes around the world.
And as more people learn English,
more varieties of English are developing.
It's even the language of the air
and of the sea, Aviation
English and Seaspeak.
In fact, English language
education is considered so crucial
that 138 countries require
English to be taught
as part of the mandatory core curriculum.
That's 70% of the countries in the world,
and another 40 offered as
an optional course of study.
So in total, at least 91%
of countries have some sort
of formal English language curriculum.
But the real question is why English,
and why not some other language?
Let's jump in.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is "Otherwords".
- [Speaker] "Otherwords".
- English wasn't always that popular.
In fact, French used to be the
go-to language for diplomacy
and business when
communicating between entities
that didn't share the same language,
otherwise known as a lingua franca.
Now, lingua franca literally
means language of the Franks,
which at the time
of its creation, really referred
to all Western Europeans,
not just the people who
live in what is now France.
It derives its same
from the original Lingua
Franca, capital L, capital F,
which developed in the Mediterranean
basin through borrowing
from several languages
and was used for trade
and diplomacy in that area from
the 11th to 18th centuries.
Capitalized Lingua Franca is actually
a pigeon language, but that's
a topic for another day.
Back to French.
After the Norman Conquest
in the 11th century, William
the Conquerer installed
French-speaking nobles to rule England,
who quickly replaced English
with French in all domains
of power, from the courts
of law to the church.
Although the peasants still spoke English,
the aristocracy maintained French
as their preferred language
for the next few hundred years.
And by the 14th century,
French was the most widely
spoken language in Europe.
By the 17th century, France
was the leading land power
in Europe, and French was well established
as the language of prestige,
replacing Latin
as the language of diplomacy
in international relations.
So why aren't we all
speaking French right now?
Well, one, we aren't all diplomats,
but even if we were,
there was a huge global power
shift in the the 20th century,
(canon fires)
the World Wars.
English was already predominant
in the technology
and innovation sectors thanks
to the Industrial Revolution.
But after the first World War,
the negotiated treaties were
written not just in French,
but also English, which was a big deal,
giving English space
in the diplomacy scene.
After World War II,
France was frankly no
longer a dominant power.
English, the defacto language
of the new major economic powerhouse,
the United States, became the language
of the economy, and money talks.
Put simply, English is
the most popular language
in the world because of money and power.
And American English
is particularly popular
because of pop culture
influences imported all
over the world, including
TV, music, food, and cinema.
So that answers our first question,
but what about the second one?
Why are there so many
different varieties of English?
Well, first, there is
no set standard English.
Unlike French, whose
standard on everything
from usage and vocabulary to grammar,
and even the dictionary,
is enforced by the Academie Francaise,
English does not have
any such authoritative
governing body determining correctness,
which means we get a lot
of variation between Englishes
spoken all around the world,
and they're all proper
and authentic Englishes.
Beyond that, it's really the same reason
why anyone talks differently
from anyone else.
There are cultural, social,
historical, political,
and geographical factors that contribute
to the way we all speak.
Within the United States,
we see English as based
on cultural heritage,
like African-American
English, Chicano English,
and Cajun English,
or on a region like Pittsburghese
or Appalachian English.
And if you're from England,
you know the difference
between Yorkshire and Lancaster English,
even though the counties are only two
and a half hours apart.
Many global Englishes are
influenced by local languages.
For example, Singapore
English or Singlish,
which is based on British English
because of that Colonial history,
includes elements such
as discourse particles, and loan words
from other local languages,
including Malay, Hokkien,
and Tamil.
The same is true with Nigerian English,
where there weren't
words in British English
that expressed certain cultural concepts
that were then borrowed
from Native languages of the region.
Linguists have attempted to organize
the various Englishes into a model.
The most famous is Braj
Kachru's three-circle paradigm
where countries are labeled
inner circle, outer circle,
and expanding circle.
The inner circle contains the countries
whose primary language is English.
The outer circle contains
countries where English
is used as an official
language or a second language,
typically countries that were
colonized by the inner circle.
And the expanding circle is
where English is widely used
but learned as a foreign language.
In other words, everywhere else.
This lends a hierarchical vibe,
but if you've been
following along, you know
that no one language is
better than any other.
There are multiple scenarios
about what could happen next.
Maybe all of our Englishes will converge
because we're all so
much more interconnected,
or oppositely,
in a Tower of Babel moment,
they'll become so different
as to be mutually unintelligible.
Unlikely.
More likely,
if English doesn't remain
the most widely spoken,
it's because another economic
powerhouse sways the tide
of language popularity
in a different direction.
But for now, English is the
foremost world language.
In an increasingly globalized world,
the most important and exciting part
about all these different Englishes
is the fact that if you speak English,
you can communicate with
literally a billion more people
than you otherwise could.
And if you can speak multiple languages,
well, then you're ahead of the game.
Replacing Latin as a language of diplomacy
and international relations.
Now, lingua franca,
literal, franca, franca.
English wasn't always that popular.
Back to French.